so the the the way we process
information the other environmental
stimuli is based on the neurons they
talk to each other the process and the
make a decision there are too many two
ways of communications one is they
through the release of neurotransmitters
the other one is they I mentioned
through gap junctions so the basic idea
is that we want to develop an new
genetically encoded non-invasive method
to image the gap Junction communication
so it's based on the it's a channel
between cells we want in the one cell we
wanted to generate a specific small
molecule as a mediator and in the other
side the media in the world goes through
the gap Junction and the in the kinetic
cell there's a sensor for this small
mediator so once we triggered one cell
there's a response in the other cell
then this demonstrate that these two
cells are communicated by gap junctions
that's the basic idea so so for now we
know that the main function for
electrical synapses is synchronize
neurons firing like those neurons are
connected by gap junctions they were
fired together so they will release
transmitters together if you don't know
how to code you spend more time on
boring stuff and be less efficient